so you ready let's go through one two
three
he's our equation step 1 you'd have to
write the steps but I'm gonna do it so
while I'm doing my check off this team I
want to find the y-intercept first okay
so I'm gonna write y-intercept
that's just my appreciation to find the
y-intercept what do I do
I just look at the value of C what's the
value of C in this case it's 5 the
y-intercept is 5 that was the hot ok
next step I want to find the
x-intercepts
that's alright thanks to the sense okay
how do I find the x-intercepts
I let y equal 0 you can see it there in
red okay so he's why let's make him 0
okay I get this equation x squared plus
6x plus 5 equals 0 you did these kinds
of questions to death right in fact this
is a really easy one can anyone
factorize it for me okay
now think carefully you gotta really
this is actually it's slightly sneaky um
I'm looking for a pair of numbers that
adds to something and multiplies to
something but which ones which do why I
want it to multiply to 6 or add to 6 in
this case I want it to add right and
this is the number I want to multiply by
usually this number right here on the
end see usually it's a bigger number but
as you can see it's not always okay so
that was a bit sneaky right I want two
numbers that add to 6 multiply the 5
what am I going to change 5 and 1 in
fact 5 is prime so 105 are pretty much
all I'm gonna have unless this hurts
thankfully there aren't so one in five
is what you told me
so one in five is what I'm going to
stick in to my factorization
okay now factorize but I haven't solved
and solved I want X equals what am I to
now you need one and they give five
fantastic ok so let's just check that
okay hey presto I've done step two I
found the x-intercepts ok now this last
little step beyond the axis and then the
vet
okay so I'm gonna write step three axis
okay
remember I said oh if you can't find any
x-intercepts that's okay
you can do this okay you can put x
equals minus B on to a let's just
quickly try that and see what happens
x equals what's B in this case it's six
very good negative six and then on the
denominator I have to aim
what's a in this case it's one it's
hiding I haven't written it there but
that's because multiplying by one
doesn't change anything
so 2 times 1 is just 2 okay now this is
a really simple fraction I'll just
simplify that it's negative 3 okay
but this shows us something which is
kind of handy which is a another useful
trick you can have up your sleeve right
you can find the axis of symmetry
without finding the roots but if you
find the roots you've more or less found
the axis of symmetry can you see why
have a look there's a relationship going
on with you right you look at these
roots and then you look at the axis of
symmetry what's the relationship between
them there's it's bang in the middle
right it's in fact it is the midpoint of
the roots that's exactly what you'd
expect because it is after all the axis
of symmetry it's the part in the middle
it had better be in the middle right
so therefore if you've got the roots
just just take the value in between you
take the Arab region or you can do that
all right now I said I want to use the
axis of symmetry to find this guy the
vertex okay now a vertex or the vertex
rather um it's a point right I get to
point up here or a point down yeah okay
I don't have enough to define where a
point is right I need one extra piece of
information what do I need if I've got
an X I'll need a wire and I need
coordinates don't I right so any Y and
then I'll know exactly where it is okay
so I will take that x value the one you
just found the axis of symmetry I'm
going to stick that guy where is there
back into my original equation okay I'm
gonna put the axis of symmetry into the
equation and that will hand me a y-value
okay so let's give it a go
for the vertex I'll say y equals and I'm
gonna put it negative three everywhere I
see X right with that so let's just do a
straight substitution what should
negative sides it's really easy to
forget to put a negative in there
you could appeal to your calculator to
do this if you like I think these
numbers the reason if we can do negative
3 squared 9 6 times negative 3 minus 18
plus 5 okay
9 minus 18 I can do that that's negative
9 and then I add 5 which is negative 4
ok and again your calculator can check
that so now I have together with this x
value I have a y value you put them
together and you get coordinates namely
negative 3 negative 4 okay I've got all
my clues that's all the pieces I need in
fact I would just circle all of them in
green there's the y intercept there's
the X intercepts there's my vertex right
there ok so now I know where I need to
draw this okay for instance do you
notice a whole bunch of these numbers
are negative negative negative on it can
be so that tells you where on the graph
you're gonna need to be and then I've
got my y intercepts which is positive
it's fine okay so because I know what
this is the graph looks like already and
we've got these values let's try a set
of axes like this okay now do you see
and I will help you see it right in a
second if you if it's not revealing to
you do you see why I've drawn my axes in
a funny way like I've hardly got any
values over here right the reason why is
because when I think horizontally in
terms of the x axis um I don't have any
positive values I don't know if I don't
have one positive x value right this is
positive but it's a y-value negative
negative negative
so everything's real
the business end of this Breville is
having over here does that make sense
okay all right let's put all the values
we've got put them on the ground I'm
going through the menorah y-intercept is
5 so if I go 1 2 3 4 5 bang
that's where I am okay because you're
going to put a whole bunch of marks on
here to this set of axes I tend to
indicate the places where I go through
these guys I put X's okay questions
all right y-intercept I check
x-intercepts of all my x axis now I need
negative 1 and negative 5
ok so I'm going to do this 3 4 5
there's one there and there's the other
one over there negative 5 okay now just
worth noting I have made my vertical
scale and my horizontal scale I've made
them more or less identical I mean it's
not you didn't you saw I didn't get a
rule around or anything but it's close
enough okay you probably should try to
get them as close as you can but if you
get some ridiculous numbers like suppose
I found this is negative 1 this is
negative 5 and then when I crunched the
numbers I got a wire deceptive 200 okay
please don't draw your 200 like you know
just pieced together three pieces of
paper so I can make it up there or in
the same way
don't make is 200 and then thief oh holy
cow if that's 200 then this is 200 and
then important negative 1 and negative 5
like in there and get my microscope out
okay don't do that just just make the
scales different okay you're the boss of
this parabola you can tell it where to
go and those scales don't need to be the
same they just need to be consistent
okay so this is 1 2 3 4 5 for instance
when I put this number down here since
this is negative 4 or I should say
negative 3 negative 4 so here's negative
3 horizontally and I'm gonna go down 1 2
3 4
that's where my vertex is okay now
remember I said your scale has to be
consistent if I'm saying that's fine
then this distance better be roughly
similar to this distance if I say
negative for like the vertex is up here
or busted like they're not anywhere
comparable to each other okay so this is
what I mean by scales being consistent
I'm going on my clues I'm ready to go up
well we'll put one more thing on there
which is on the last point of redundant
vertex you should actually put a tiny
tiny horizontal line through it that
seems a bit unusual
you're not going to deal with any of
those other points that you did the
reason why is because a very common
mistake that students make when they
draw these parabolas is they draw them
too sharp right see my are my shapes
here these are nice curvy travelers lots
of people draw their parabolas kind of
like that right or even worse like with
a point at the bottom okay that isn't
nice shape you might learn about it in
the next couple years but it's not a
parabola it's gotta be curved it's got
to come down gently to the vertex okay
so drawing a horizontal line there just
like I have a little horizontal line
here and a little horizontal line there
it kind of forces you to make the shape
a little more accurate doesn't do
everything but it's pretty close okay
ready go no just gonna join the dots
okay I've got on one two three dots
going this way so I'm gonna join them up
first looks like something like this
there we go okay now it's wet lady you
know I mean admittedly I did it freehand
but it's pretty common not to nail that
on your first step okay you've got three
dots to hit and you've got to try and
get that shape really nice as well
please please for the love of graphs
drawing pencil okay
I like a small number of people I can
count on one hand you can draw perfect
travel of first time every time and the
rest of us mere mortals we have to be
willing to make a mistake fix it up it's
fine rub it out and give it another shot
okay I've done one side parabola is
symmetrical so the other side ought to
look exactly the same just facing the
other way happy times I'm finished just
to make a really neat this is not
essential but it'll become more useful
later on I've drawn this I should label
it it has a name namely the equation
that we started with okay and that's it
the reason why it's important to have an
equation there is as you see in about 10
minutes if you've got more than one
graph on here right if you've got other
shapes colliding with this you want to
know which ones which so that's why we
label them any questions on that
explanation of graphic colors pretty
much no I mean okay what a marks about
in a in an assessment marks your back
does this didn't understand what's going
on right a three out of three means
yeah they understand everything and one
out of three is like what happens then
something they don't understand nothing
but clearly there are some problems with
this line oh they put the five as a
negative five that they don't understand
the y-intercept or something like that
okay so does this label up here
represent an understanding what's going
on if I draw a graph that looks like
this
I think this student understands us
chorion however the reason I'm still
gonna put my equation up there is
because as you'll see what I do this is
this next part movie yeah
not because it's do I understand or not
but when I have lots of equations flying
around and you can bet your bottom
dollar when you get into unit you have
lots of equations you will be forced to
put multiple drafts on one set of axes
right you really want to know which ones
which and it will just confuse you when
you don't label right if you don't label
you're not costing yourself any marks
you're just costing yourself getting
confused later on when you're like wait
which graph is which again because you
know when you're under pressure you
don't have a lot of time it's just too
easy to mistake one thing for another
okay so a lot of that marks for me I
think if you graph that and everything
except the labels on there
you've clearly demonstrated you know
what's going on and you've mastered this
process but you should do it I do it it
helps you okay
the question